the US soldiers facing federal charges
for allegedly sharing bomb-making
instructions online and wanting to
attack a major news network
he also made reference to a twenty20
presidential candidate Jeff the gates
reports on what we're learning about
this soldier private first class Jared
Smith is accused in an FBI affidavit of
leading a group chat on facebook where
he bragged about his ability to build an
improvised explosive device or ie D in
one message Smith allegedly told someone
we can make cellphone IEDs in the style
of the Afghans I can teach you that the
affidavit alleges Smith also discussed a
plan of conducting an attack within the
US and wanted to target the headquarters
of a major American news network
allegedly CNN with a vehicle bomb he
also allegedly plotted to kill far
left-leaning activists known as an tyfa
and wanted to travel to Ukraine to fight
with a violent far-right group he was
charged with one count of distributing
information related to explosives and
weapons of mass destruction Catherine's
White is a former FBI special agent this
subject routinely provided advice and
direction on how to build bombs that's
frightening investigators say Smith also
mentioned Democratic presidential
candidate beta O'Rourke
according to the affidavit an undercover
agent asked Smith whether there was
anyone down in Texas that would be a
good fit for fire destruction and death
Smith allegedly responded outside of
bait oh I don't know enough people that
would be relevant enough to cause a
change if they died O'Rourke thanked law
enforcement Monday for keeping everyone
safe we have been sharing any
information that's relevant with the FBI
Jeff Pegues reporting for us Jeff thank
you very much